poll question McLovin then we'll bring
in bill plants key from the only times
who's had a worst post season Lakers or
the Celtics 64% say Lakers
well let me start there with Bill plashy
from the LA Times and of course around
the horn who's had a worse post season
Lakers or Celtics bill oh the Lakers and
it's not even close States they've
messed up they've gotten swept out of
the series without even taking the court
yeah it's the Lakers I mean they had it
just it was AM it's amazing what
happened this week is they had the one
coach who can coach LeBron James the one
coach who wanted to be here wanted to
come here and coach him who had a chance
at you know some success with him and
they couldn't close it and if one coach
they wanted their only coach the only
quotes you offered a job to and it
couldn't close the deal and you let him
walk away it's it's nuts it's nuts out
here and you know it's it's they seem
very rudderless in the front office
right now they seem like nobody really
knows what's going on but I'm wondering
that there was talk about perception and
reality and if you brought in ty ty Lu
and then everybody's gonna think LeBrons
bring in you know we're placating lebron
i who cares about your the lakers who
cares about perception give me reality
did we get the right guy give him five
years and I applaud ty lue for saying
hey I don't want to be LeBron's Lackey
here I want to be the Laker coach not
hey let's tie it into LeBrons contract
and if he's gone in three years then I'm
gone so why not just give him five years
Luke Walton got it Monty Williams got it
why not ty lue bill yeah it's you know
what it's incredible and I think I think
down deep the Lakers are the Lakers hate
to hate the idea in fact I know this for
a fact
they hate the idea that they've given
the whole key to the whole relation to
LeBron they hate that idea they hate
that notion but they have to live with
it they did it and you know they made
this deal with him last year and and and
this is how it works with him and I
think they've they've buckled under that
notion and so this was their way of
saying well we'll take you but only for
three years and you know only and it's
as soon as the broadleaves you've got to
leave and we're just doing this just
just out of you know because this is
what he wants and we really don't want
it so they stated they were acting like
we want you but we really don't want you
and if the reality is he's the one guy
who's won a championship with LeBron
he's the one guy who would
and all the backstabbing and whispering
that would happen the next couple years
if somebody else comes in here he's the
one guy that would have to help them
salvage salvage what is you know the
last twenty two or three years of this
LeBron nightmare and they I think
they're prod got in the way and they say
what the Lakers and what bigger than
that well guess what they're not they're
not they're a desperate team right now
six straight years without the playoffs
they needed this guy it should have
closed this deal and it leads to the you
know the questions about Jeannie buses
her leadership and what is Rob palinka
doing running your basketball operations
that's that's the that's the amazing
thing she should have the whole thing
what could have been avoided if Ginny
bus had replaced Magic Johnson with a
smart bright forward-thinking basketball
executive from the outside to run things
and handle the coaching search and said
she stayed with sit within the
quote-unquote Laker family and it's
blowing up on her but Bill is this you
know come down to something as simple of
who's in charge here are there too many
people in charge yeah well there's also
that there's also a lot of a lot of some
of the people that our office wanted
Monty Williams and I think someone you
know the louder ones one two tyloo and
they won and then when tyloo started
balking ago she ations the other ones
they will omit let's let's just stop
this yeah that who is in charge Jeanne
well it's a genie bus is it Linda Rambis
who is a shadow owner is it Kurt Rambis
it's helping conduct the coaching search
what is Kurt Rambis doing helping
conducting the coaching search for any
team but he's part of the deal he's part
of the one isn't ones interviewing
candidates so yeah it's hard to know
who's voice is loudest in there but
whoever's voice it is I think all the
voices together have have combined to
perform a to have a very listenable
inaudible message to the fans the fans
are furious fans out here are furious at
what's going on at the you know at the
discord and the dysfunction they see
everyday these bill plash gate from the
LA Times and of course around the horn
in his column today bill writes marinate
in the idea that Laker land is becoming
a wasteland soaked in the notion that
show time is turning toxic say hello to
the Los Angeles Knicks call the Pulitzer
committee call the Senate to the
Pulitzer committee there
but I get the feeling the Knicks might
have a better sense of what they at
least have a coach bill and and maybe
have a better sense of what direction
they're going in even though they have
dysfunction you know starting with their
ownership well
Kevin Durant Kevin Durant apparently it
could be on track to take the Knicks
over the Lakers because of the toxic
environment down here yes and they've
been they've got a head coach and they
have they have an idea and they have a
draft pick the Lakers are going into the
so they're gonna go into the draft camp
next week in the combine and all that
stuff with no head coach with no
directions with no plot philosophy
moving forward and I thought there was
necessary to get a head coach by the end
of this week and we all followers Lou
we're all waiting for the press
conference retire Lou Tyler we had a
birthday party in which he had a Laker
themed cake I'm sure you all talked
about this on there he was he was he was
cutting the cake and celebrating
drinking champagne is a new Laker coach
and the Lakers in the Lakers wouldn't
wouldn't give him the extra two years
that's that's nuts I mean that's funny
if you want to fire up to three years
fire back three years but at least give
me impression of five years yes you can
afford it give him five years what every
money Williams got five years Luke
Walton the guy he replaced got five
years in Sacramento so Lakers again
again I think it's Jeanie buss and Rob
pálinka are just lost right now but now
you look at the candidates you got Frank
Vogel Mike Woodson you got Juwan Howard
Lionel Hall
don't even mention Jason Kidd oh my
goodness I can't imagine yeah I think
what happens now is they find somebody
LeBron can can deal with or they trade
LeBron and I think and I think there's
some people in their front office that
would like to get rid of LeBron at this
point but he's already been more trouble
than he's worth to them and I think
maybe one of their ways of doing this
would be to get a coach he doesn't like
and mayo force his hand to say I went
out I mean that could be that could be
one of the you know I can't imagine they
do that with the grip with the arguably
the greatest player ever but that could
be one of their one of their thinking's
here but I don't see any you know that's
the thing the head coach if you don't
get the right guy you're in for a lot of
you know backstabbing and a lot of you
mouths intention on the bench and then
and in you and you're in it and you
could end up and have betrayed this guy
so yeah I don't know where they go from
here but it doesn't seem pretty where it
is the way the best thing to do would be
to call pilu back and say okay take six
for two years I take the extra two I
just come here yeah I'm sure um sure we
saw some of that cake left in
refrigerator pull out that cake have
another bite come on join us now that's
the best thing they can do
oh man you just you know I know it's
exhausting it's C oh they're not playing
a game I'm playing for six years in this
month it's all I'm exhausted
are you on around the what you have to
be on around the horn tonight right no
no no that that schedules is a week in
advance I'm not here and and callous
wrong with the Cabo so he's not on
either so it's a very disappointing
very disappointing day for where he I
one-two-three Cabo for for college all
today what if you could just talk to one
person and they you were gonna get the
the whole truth here what would you want
to sit down with this organization and
just say alright
oh I need answers this is the same
person well I I have pride and I've
gotten no response or no we're not
talking to you is a genie bus I mean
she's the one she's still the owner
she's still the board of it she's still
the one I mean you know she's still the
one running the show you know you could
I mean I guess if you wanted some real I
guess if you know I mean she'll be she
would give the real we don't know she's
never you know she doesn't she hasn't
lied or anything she hadn't said
anything to anybody
she hasn't been and she's supposed to be
the public face of the team she's
supposed to be accountable and you know
in the in the biggest moment here she's
failing at that badly
well alright bill you you were breathing
fire today
with your cone so uh I don't know well
thanks it again I wish I was covered a
game or something it's amazing I'm or
I'm writing more about this and I've
everything about any other games in the
last decades so yeah it's it's a
nightmare it's a nightmare
thank you Bill that's uh thank you Bill
planning LA times around the horn
contributor for more dan Patrick
tune in to audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on VR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app